we must say a big hoorah because Matt
Damon you were back at the helm of the
Bourne franchise Jason Bourne is back
yeah we're shooting it right now we're
shooting it I was being chased just last
night but I got away fear that one image
they've released so far of the new
Bourne film it's got a name by the way I
don't think it's got a name yet because
how long is it since you did the last
board it's six seven years yeah more
than that
it came out in oh seven but we shot it
in oh six so yeah it's been nine years
and in movie time it's even more because
the the third one and the second one are
supposed to dovetail like the third ax
take place at the same time so
technically James Bourne has urged James
Bourne and Jason bond is fine
[Applause]
because it I mean because getting into
that shape now is that is it more
challenging was not the same yeah I mean
I'm gonna be 45 in a couple of weeks
it's no yeah yeah that was yeah no no
it's much much harder I mean that the
first Bourne movie I did 15 years ago so
I think I turned 30 on the first one and
I'm turning 45 on this one so yeah it's
a it's a whole different thing do you
find the the choreograph fighting and
you find that easy no no I they always
put me with really good fighters and
that's the key cuz it's more like
dancing when you're when you're doing
that cuz it's not you know a real fight
people are trying to hit each other and
in these fights you're trying to just
miss each other so you have to be
completely in sync and and moving
exactly the right way or the whole if
one of you messes up it doesn't it
doesn't work so it's much more like a
dance so I'm always gonna be the weakest
dancing partner of the two these guys
are all professional fighters so they
they really like a great dancer they can
elevate the purse their partner you know
so I love the fighting in important
because chosen well he's a brilliant
improvisor
with weapons so if somebody's coming out
and with a machine gun and he'll get a
ballpoint pen yeah it ran a magazine
directory hole punch
stay practically stationary he's got a
bendy ruler
it would be a great way of stage a scene
in a stationary story yeah blue tag in
your eyes a green binder
[Applause]
I literally looked at it I was alone
with it and I said to myself thank God I
didn't [__] anybody over for this and I
suddenly had this but I will use your
ponytail to steer while you dine upon my
lady sound
[Applause]
she's what he thought it through